what's going on guys this is Rob still
not feeling my best so I apologize if
I'm not crazy over excited stomach just
bothering me a little bit but it's been
a while since we have covered the X-Men
so I figured we kind of get back into it
again now all this takes place after the
events of sins of sinister and as most
of you guys kind of figured out sins of
sinister as interesting as it was just
kind of a pointless event didn't really
serve any useful purpose that we're
aware of but the thing about this is
that this actually focuses on the X-Men
returning to the children of the Vault
now we'll talk about that here in a
second but in effect this is the
children of the Vault killing the Marvel
Universe now the cool thing about this
is that what Forge has been doing is
actually just running a series of
simulations now a little bit of
discussion here for a second about the
children of the Vault and Forge Forge is
a character that is very obscure even to
the most reasonable comic book reader if
they're not seriously reading the X-Men
and haven't really been reading the
X-Men for a long time but Forge is like
the mutant population's version of Tony
Stark that his mutant power is is his
super intelligence specifically with
regards to computer systems so much like
Tony Stark Forge can reverse engineer or
even engineer virtually anything he can
think of but if you take his mutant
power away the guy would probably have a
hard time operating an iPhone right I
mean that's just kind of the nature of
his power but what Forge has been doing
with regards to the children of the
vault is running simulations to figure
out what would happen if the children of
the Vault were to escape now in order to
explain that the the way the children of
the Vault were originally introduced to
us back in 2006 is that it was actually
an experiment by Humanity to basically
hyper-evolve humans to essentially use
them as a means to get rid of the mutant
population and So within the Vault
itself time passes differently it really
kind of accelerates more than anything
else so what would feel like 15 minutes
outside the vault is potentially two or
three hundred years within the Vault and
so when Jonathan Hickman took over the
X-Men and brought the children of the
Vault back what he showed us is that in
the far flung future seemingly at the
end of the mutant population a war
always broke out between the human and
machine Alliance the post-humans which
is what the children of the Vault become
and the mutant population and that they
all had their own individual goals but
in the end it always led to the
destruction the complete and utter
destruction of the mutant population in
one form or another and so the result to
this is that there's always kind of this
lingering fear of the children of the
Vault what it means if they were to
escape and so in running these
simulations what Forge had come to the
realization of is that if the children
were to escape because of the fact that
they are hyper-evolved beings that
basically learn from every experience
that they have they would take out
cricoa within the first day they would
literally Wipe Out the entirety of the
krakowan island now I want to specify
here this is no small thing virtually
every mutant in existence resides on
krakowa now one of the ways at which
Marvel's even able to get away with this
stuff right now now when it comes to the
events of sins of sinister or this
particular set of circumstances is
remember when it comes to Franklin
Richards Marvel depowered him right he's
not a mutant with reality warping
abilities anymore he's just a kid that
exists out there otherwise this would
have been almost impossible to get away
with Franklin could just walk up and
snap his fingers and everything gets
taken care of and like that's the end of
that he's a giant walking talking
MacGuffin is basically what he is but in
the absence of that cacawa falls in one
day the following day after that the
children of the Vault take out the
entirety of the Avengers and then within
the third day and probably within like a
few weeks after that following defeats
Retreat to the Vault basically learning
and then developing new abilities to
counter the powers that had killed them
in the first place they re-emerge they
take on Asgard and they wipe out Asgard
and it just repeats itself over and over
and over again to the point that in
effect these post-humans Wipe Out the
entirety of the Marvel Universe within
an exceedingly short amount out of time
right it's not like it was a sense of
sinister where it took the mutant
population hundreds of years to
completely conquer the universe now this
happens within probably one year right
one year after emerging from the from
the Vault the children wipe out
everything and they conquer the entirety
of the universe just like that and in
fact even Dr Doom Falls and one of the
things they specify is that with Dr Doom
and specifically latviria that's where
all the magic wielders Retreat Doctor
Strange were really clear because Doctor
Strange is already dead at that point in
time but like Jericho drum all those
guys Dr Doom is like the last man
standing the last human in existence and
in one of the coolest moments that
Doctor Doom has he's like this is not
over when you get to hell I'll be
waiting for you like it's the most
Doctor Doom thing to say before he gets
annihilated but it's just this really
really cool depiction now I love the way
that Marvel does this because they don't
like turn it into an event right it's
not like this big crossover event Marvel
could have done that it's just not kind
of a half-assed cash graph but they just
decided not to and I love that they
didn't because running the simulations
and coming to the realization this is
the only way that this scenario can play
out what Forge does is he constructs an
entire Dome around the entrance to the
children of the Vault so when they
emerge this entire version of them
conquering everything in existence is
all a simulation for them it's not
actually happening they just believe
that it does and it keeps them passive
right it keeps them under control right
it keeps them believing that they've
dominated everything so there's no
reason for them to look any further it's
a pretty smart maneuver by Forge in
order to keep their greatest threat
completely and totally under their
control here's the problem right in the
early days when Hickman was writing the
X-Men there was a mission that was
undertaken by the X-Men themselves to
investigate the Vault before any of this
stuff unfolded you had sync you had
Darwin and you had Laura Kinney x-23 now
Laura Kinney x23 most all of you guys
know who she is right like the female
clone of Wolverine Darwin is an Omega
Level mutant that has the ability to
adapt to anything and in fact in this
comic that dude basically becomes
Godlike in terms of his powers it's kind
of nuts and we'll we'll talk about that
as we get through this sync was the only
one who was able to escape now Sync has
the ability to basically duplicate the
powers of anybody around him more
recently his power has been elevated to
a higher level so he can copy multiple
abilities at once and he doesn't have to
be around them anymore to do it it's
like pulling out cards from a Rolodex
it's awesome right he's basically Peter
Petrelli from Heroes right it's just he
is I would argue he's probably the most
powerful mutant that Marvel has right
now in this moment right this guy is
ridiculously op because it feels like
there's no upper limit to the powers
that he possesses the problem with this
is that even though he was able to
escape he was in the vault for hundreds
of years he and Laura Kinney they built
a life together had a romantic
relationship going on but when he made
his Escape he never ever talked about
what went on inside the Vault and with
Laura and Darwin still being stuck there
he's really just seems to be dealing
with a combination of depression and
post-traumatic stress disorder right so
he just won't talk about any of it at
all it's just one of those weird things
and the telepaths could poke in prod but
they choose not to the reason why this
is all important is because what Forge
does is basically orchestrate a rescue
mission for Darwin to focus on him
because with Darwin's ability to adapt
one it's believed that Laura Kinney's
dead and two because Darwin could adapt
to anything he's most likely survived
and given his longevity and everything
he's witnessed in the vault the
information he could bring back would be
Paramount not just because of the fact
that it would allow the X-Men to
withstand virtually any assault by the
children of the Vault if they were to
escape the dome but also because it
could actually allow the X-Men to expand
their own abilities and become more
powerful than they are right now and so
what we end up learning is that even
around the Dome as a kind of safety
measure to make sure that nobody could
just break in there that Forge had set
it up so the Dome would develop its own
ecosystem I.E its own kind of security
Force now it's not as though they
answered to the X-Men they're designed
to be autonomous and Forge really even
makes this case because if he were to
Die the Dome would fail and there would
be no protection from the children of
the Vault emerging and so what this
meant is that there had to be some kind
of additional security there so these
guys are I mean they're they're okay I
mean they're not overly powerful the
centuries are dealt with pretty readily
by the X-Men which really begs the
question how relevant could these guys
be if the X-Men could overcome them I
mean you would think that Forge would
have some kind of security installed
that not even the X-Men could get around
it but if that were the case how in the
world do they get inside the vault in
the first place so it's kind of a
finicky situation but what ends up
happening is Forge uses a suit of his
own design using a combination of
mystique's abilities to basically take
on a physical form other than her own as
well as DNA that belonged to caliban now
caliban is a mutant that has the ability
to track down any other mutants within a
particular range right I think I want to
say it's like two or three miles but
that's fluctuated over the years in
Marvel Comics and in fact there's been
stories where caliban can track the
movements of mutants around the world
right so it really just depends on who's
telling the story at that point in time
but using these two abilities what it
does is it allows Forge to appear as one
of the children of the Vault when he
enters but using the powers of caliban
it allows him to track the location of
Darwin as long as caliban knows what
Darwin's signal is which caliban does
and so as he enters into the Vault one
of the things that happens is he passes
by these kind of stasis pods which
basically houses what we could call the
core members of the children or the ones
that basically the ones that lead the
assault against everybody else and so
because of the nature of their powers
and the fact that their powers are so
Advanced the only way to pacify them is
to keep them in stasis pods and keep
them locked there right because even
with this Dome and this whole simulation
and everything that it does serve a
purpose right most everybody else that's
inside the main Vault itself they're
just living out their lives right the
ones who are like wiping everything out
in existence this is the dream they're
living inside those pods but as long as
they're contained and as long as they're
kept in stasis everything is going to be
copacetic right like everything's going
to be fine and so what ends up going on
is that once Forge passes through we end
up finding that within within the Vault
itself is an entire civilization
millions of people live there right and
they all have varying degrees of powers
we don't really know what their powers
are except for the ones that are inside
those stasis pods but there's a whole
civilization down there they live their
lives they form family bonds and all
kinds of stuff right they pair off and
couple and all those different things
it's cool like it's a really really cool
concept but donning the appearance of
perro right like one of the children of
the Vault and kind of walking around
through there no one seems to be any the
wiser except for one person and we'll
find out who they are but one of the
other issues that transpires is Scott
Summers and Alex Summers get into a
fight now this isn't new these guys
fight all the time they've been doing it
since the introduction of Havoc into the
X-Men comics and even when he was on X
Factor they fight like cats and dogs and
their brothers so it makes perfect sense
the problem is that given the fight
between the two of them when Cyclops is
punched by havoc in knox's visor off his
face and optic blast fires off and it
hits one of the stasis pods which frees
the real para right like the actual guy
who believes that they've conquered
everything when he re-emerges he comes
to the realization they were duped they
were tricked the entire stasis pod was
like an illusion they didn't conquer
anything and so what follows is not
overly important it's basically a
conflict between like the X-Men and this
one guy but it is worth covering here
for a couple different reasons one of
the first things that happens is he
punches Iceman and shatters him now that
doesn't matter right for Bobby Drake he
can just turn into a liquid form piece
himself back together and come back
right he's basically invulnerable so
long as he's able to access the
different portions of himself but one of
the things he points out is that this
guy is as strong as the Incredible Hulk
which basically it shows how it is that
even just on the front of strength they
were able to overtake most all the
Avengers and the X-Men right and then
following that the rest of the X-Men
step in and basically fight where they
can when they can but for the most part
they're not able to do a whole lot in
terms of just brunt strength facing off
against this guy a lot of it really
comes down to Gene using her telepathic
powers in order to take over this guy's
mind pacify him convince him that what's
been going on right now is a nightmare
and the reality or at least the idea of
them conquering everything that's the
true world he lives in they put him back
in the stasis pod and everything's more
or less sorted out not the biggest deal
in the world but it does show just how
capable this guy is and the level of
power Just One of these children of the
Vault possesses and that's the funny
thing right say for example that this
guy were able to at the very least not
really kill the X-Men but like
incapacitate them and head back into the
Vault that he would be subjected to kind
of I wouldn't say reconditioning but
like a restructuring of his power given
the fight he had with the X-Men and then
in turn he would come out stronger than
he was before so it's kind of a cool
thing right it's like he's almost kind
of like uh those are guys who are
familiar with doomsday from DC Comics
think of all the children of the Vault
operating in that capacity right they're
always just kind of reworked
restructured and improved upon given
their previous feelings but switching
back to forge because the real pero is
thrown back into his stasis fault it
allows uh it allows Force to continue on
masquerading as pero once he gets past
the security with the main Vault itself
and the AI this constantly working to
improve the different members of the
children here that once he gets in he
realizes Laura Kinney's actually alive
right she's alive and she's being kept
there and is constantly feeding on her
DNA in order to restructure and to
develop new abilities within the
children of the Vault itself this is
where their healing Factor comes from
right each one of them whenever it is
that they are injured they basically
experience the healing factor of Laura
Kinney and it allows them to survive but
the Lord Kinney healing factor is
constantly approved upon with each
generation of the children of the Vault
being reworked and restructured and sent
back out again so it's cool the problem
with this is that Ford says that she's
not the mission and so Ford puts her
back in stasis right he just kind of
walks away which is kind of a shady
thing but it also makes sense at the
same time because trying to launch a
rescue mission for two people when one
is going to be a struggle in and of
itself it would basically turn into a
suicide mission and the reality here is
that even with caliban attached to him
that if the children of the Vault were
able to get their hands on the power of
caliban then there would be no Escape
there'd be no way to get out of this
rather be no way to get away from this
and the biggest reason why is because
where a war could break out between the
children of the Vault and the Marvel
Universe specifically the X-Men the
X-Men could run and hide they could
Marshal their forces they could gather
back together they could launch another
attack but with the power of caliban at
the children of the vault's disposal
that in turn there would be nowhere for
the X-Men to hide that ultimately the AI
would basically evolve the powers of
caliban to where it could determine the
location of any Mutant on Earth anywhere
in the earth and it would only be a
matter of time before all the X-Men are
hunted down there's nowhere to run
there's nowhere to hide there's nowhere
they could Retreat you maybe space they
could take off into space but even then
they would eventually be found right so
it's a really kind of a kind of an
interesting moment because what happens
is Forge realizes that okay our main
mission is to find Darwin but I don't
know where this guy is enter Seraphina
and that's the person that we find out
has actually been following Forge around
this entire time because she seemingly
realized right off the bat that Forge is
not the real parrot now a lot of this
seems to be due to the fact that as soon
as he entered the Vault it took him a
minute or two but then he put on his
disguise she seems to have spotted him
between that time period and has just
been following him around now Seraphina
she's interesting and unique among the
children of the Vault I would not go so
far as to say that she is the most
powerful although admittedly as she
appears now that seems to be the case
but we don't definitively know the
nature of our powers Now versus before
when we originally saw her she was a
technopath meaning she could interface
with technology she could like teleport
she could cloak herself right she had
the ability to throw basically
adamantium knives although it was kind
of an unstable version of adamantium so
it wasn't as like pure or good as like
wolverines adamantium is bought it to
his bones what she looks like here and
she looks like she's a walking talking
adamantium being right like her entire
body is encased in adamantium now even
if it is the unstable version that
normally makes up her knives it still
makes her incredibly durable and I would
go as far as to say almost
indestructible if it is a purified
version of adamantium or even a more
pure version than the one that Wolverine
has there's no way to kill this girl
there's absolutely no way to destroy her
outside of some high level reality
warping character who could disperse her
molecules across the cosmos there's
seemingly no no possible way to destroy
this chick using Brute Force most likely
even telepathy because even given
something like Magneto's helmet that can
block telepathic thoughts from entering
his head surely the children of the
Vault had considered that and adapted it
but of course the funny thing about this
is that she's not really interested in
killing Forge if anything she's more
interested in gaining information
specifically she asked him are you the
one responsible for constructing the
Trap outside of the vault door basically
this illusion that the children of the
Vault successfully conquer everything in
existence the response of Forge is yes
now the reason he's being truthful here
is because she told him if you lie I'll
kill you on the spot and she would right
like she would literally kill him right
there so it's in his best interest to
tell the truth and so when she asked the
question why he said the alternative was
simply war and she says correct again
what was the ulterior motive and he says
because I wanted to see what would
happen and she says I believe you and
that's the same reason I'm allowing you
to take your mutant and go my skills are
balanced I want to see how this will end
so what's really more curiosity than
anything else now a lot of this is also
due to the fact that if the X-Men were
not concerned about the power of the
children of the Vault they would not
have constructed this entire illusion in
the first place but the fact that they
did that basically shows that they're
concerned about the children of the
Vault emerging and that most likely it
was an act of self-preservation I.E the
X-Men saw their own death with the
children of the Vault and so her
response here is really more rooted in
the idea of I'm not worried about you
because I know that we would end up
killing you anyway and like that's it
and she walks away it's the ultimate
power play it's really really awesome
now the issue here is that given the
injury that Ford sustained he ultimately
passes out and when he does he wakes up
in what he perceives as being his Grand
Vision for what kakawa would look like
and I'll be honest it looks pretty dope
like it's a very utopian landscape Farm
a more Grand in scale than krakowa as it
exists right now but what ends up
happening is that as he makes his way
through here he's basically met by
Darwin now that's one of the things that
I want to point out here and this is why
I say Darwin has achieved a whole new
level of power because what Darwin
reveals to forge here is that he has no
physical form anymore he did at one
point in time and given the fact that
his body could adapt to virtually any
situation the AI was constantly
experimenting on him and in fact he even
refers to it as a living autopsy right
like they were cutting up in his head
they were experimenting on his brain
they were doing all kinds of different
things just subjecting him to pain and
torture and all that kind of stuff in
the pursuit of knowledge but eventually
Darwin Broke Free of his physical form
now this is exceedingly important here
because as an Omega Level mutant that is
why all Sanders of measurement Immortal
and can adapt involuntarily right to any
situation he's indestructible and by
being able to enter into the mind of
Forge and then show him a reality that
otherwise doesn't exist I mean this
isn't Marvel giving us a definitive
explanation of his powers I would argue
this guy's reached godhood now right I
mean he even goes as far as his health
Forge I don't want to leave this place
right having no physical form it allows
me to observe these people here to learn
about these people here I'm not ready to
return which this is basically just
marvel saying hey guys Darwin's still
around we just haven't brought him back
yet but like we will and things are
going to pop off when he does come back
because he's now the most powerful
mutant that ever existed in the history
of Marvel Comics the guy's so powerful
he doesn't need a physical form right I
mean how do you beat a guy like that
right that's just a disembodied voice
that can control the world around him I
mean it's insane and so in response to
that Forge does the only thing he can do
he actually ends up grabbing Laura
Kinney and then making their escape and
so once they get out you have the X-Men
that contacts sync and sync despite a
total unwillingness to return to the
Vault due to his loyalty as an X-Man
into the rest of the team shows up here
and initially he thinks it's like a
massive problem and a huge issue only to
find out that it's not that it's
basically the Revelation that Laura
Kinney's here now Cyclops tells sink hey
man she might need a little bit of time
uh we should give her time to kind of
come to terms and to figure out
everything that's going on nope Laura
Kinney goes running up on sync and I
think we all know what's going to follow
here right there's gonna be a lot of
touching of naughty bits between the two
of them
right for quite some time but it's a
cool story right it's not a great big
huge action-packed story it's not nuts
it's just kind of a transitionary story
to basically see The Return of Laura
Kinney's character x23 to Marvel Comics
but also establishing that Darwin is way
more powerful than he's ever been and
when this guy returns to the main Marvel
Universe there's no telling what this
guy is going to be capable of but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace